You're not going to believe this one. It was the last week of senior year.
So we're just getting crazy. We're about to graduate.
So we're at this park having a big cake party, just middle of the day.
So then this is this high school or high school where I went to a Catholic high
school where in our uniforms, we got to like a half day. So we were like,
let's go to the park. We've got a keg. We're out there. It's like, you know,
a hundred of us drinking. So my friend, who was like a sophomore,
his, it wasn't Pakistani. His name was like, like packing esteem,
Jeff Pakistan or something. So we called him.
He shows up with my friend, dirty Turk.
So.
Crazy kid who we let hang around us. He was way younger.
He was like two feet tall, skinny as hell. But he was, he was,
he would do anything. You said like, go jump off that building,
go say a racial slur. And in front of that guy.
But he was fearless, really shine for a little bit. I think his name's Steve-O,
he's still doing pretty good in and out of boarding school.
Like parents killed themselves in front of him. One of these kids, you know,
just seeing it all. He was up for anything. So where are we? He goes, Oh,
I got to get something. Oh, there's a house party. There's a house party.
So we jumped in my car to convertible. We jump in my car,
we're going to this house party. We're in our uniforms and everything.
And I'm trying to it's rush hour now. So I'm trying to get into a,
a lane to merge off the highway and I go, Hey man, can I get in?
Can I get in the guy goes, Nope, gives me like a hard, Nope. And I was like,
this guy. So I get in behind him and I bumped him just for the hell of it.
We're hammered, you know, it's, you know, it's.
I give him a little Taparoo. So he's like, he's in the beer. That one,
the idea of drunk driving me. I just gave her a little Taparoo Tapper.
So he's like in the mirror, like what the is going on here?
We're doing like the BA blow me heat.
A ponytail. It was a whole thing. No offense.
Whatever you drunk boat dad.
No. Um, so he's like, you I'll kill you, whatever. And then, uh, we're like, Oh,
this guy wants to play. So I tap him again. Now he puts his car in park.
Send me over the edge. That would make me so. Like if you did it, like
in the beginning, we go, what's wrong with Mark's brain. I love that. Mark goes,
Oh, this guy wants to play. Huh? So I tap them again,
say this isn't new Orleans.
So he puts the car in park. He gets out. So now we're like, Oh, this,
this is on, you know, there's two of us. I got here, back and forth.
Just lunge at him like a rat. He real quick take out his knees.
No claws neck. So, uh, he gets out and he walks past me.
So I'm kinda like ready walks past me, goes to the back of the car,
reads my license plate, memorizes. It walks back up,
slams his fist on my hood and gets in his car. And I was like, huh, well,
that was weird. So now traffic's kind of moving a little bit and I'm like,
this guy, what cop? No, no, no. He was, he had like a sandals on and shorts.
He was like a hippie kind of guy. So now I'm like, well, that was weird.
But he's on a cell phone. This is when cell phones were like,
if somebody is on a cell phone, you noticed it. The big brick. And I was like,
Oh, that's weird. So now we're on the main streets and I'm following him,
but something's up.
And then he gets to a green light stops and I stopped behind him.
Everybody's like, why isn't this guy going here in the green light?
There's a bar on the corner. A guy runs out of the bar,
jumps in my convertible. Jesus Christ, crazy.
And a leather jacket on. He was just day drinking at some bar.
It was we're like.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, Becky. So, so I'm driving now. The,
the guy in the car peels off, he's like, I'm outta here. these guys.
But my friend will handle this.
Ex-con or whatever. That guy, the guy who waits at bars for the phone call.
So Jeff,
I've been waiting for this call years. This man saved my life and I
put it on my tab, takes a drink, shoots it. He goes,
build another one. I'll be back in five fingers.
Or slings, open clink. Lingling jumps in the backseat, pulls Packy back there.
They're having fun.
This fight on their knees in the back seat, just like a cartoon
drive and looking backwards,
trying to not kill myself because we're on the street. The street is moving.
So I'm like, I'm like trying to do swings like back here,
like trying to help Packy, like doing some backward hammers, you know,
[inaudible] her children in the backseat. [inaudible] turn this car around.
Exactly creepy. So this is a man, this is a guy he's balding.
He's got a leather jacket on with patches on it. And he, you know,
he's got a half a beer. This is a dude feeding them kids.
I'm a kid. But that,
that retard mom's strength kicks in where you're just like scared for your life.
You know, fight or flight.
He's like windmill, windmill, windmill.
And uh, so I just scrapped.
Becky, push him out, push him out. It's a packet, get some kind of deal.
But he just gets up under the guy and goes, ah, the guy goes over the backseat
to the street. And then like cars buying. Try not to hit him.
Somebody runs over his hand and I'm like, Oh, the guy goes,
Oh my God, what is happening? So we go to the house party and was like,
Oh my God, you're not going to it with telling everybody I got a whole pal.
Right?
The living room. I'm like this crazy pushed about it. Wasn't saying,
and Peggy's just sitting in the corner smoking. Not saying anything.
He was a psycho.
I think he's since died. But uh, I usually have with you at all times. Yeah.
I think he's dead now. There's no way that guy's alive. Oh my God.
He got the hit or something. He took that guy seat at the bar. Yes,
exactly. That's the only way to get that.
[inaudible] it's like when you go to a dojo and you beat the mess, we wait,
wait. So how does this story end? Alright.
So we're at the party and I had a beeper at the time and it was one of those
clear beepers where you could see the electronics.
So my mom was going like call mom, mom nine one, one, mom, mom, dad,
dad called mom. We love you. What happened? You know? And I'm like, Whoa.
So I call my mom, you know, I'm like, hello, trying to be sober. And she's like,
the police are here. Get the over here. I don't know where you are.
I don't know what you did. But I got six cops in the living room.
I'm feeding them coffee. They're all waiting. You're going to jail. Come over,
hung up. And I'm like, Oh my God.
Quick. Get in the car, switch clothes with me.
I'm going to need you to be me for a month when packet getting shot on your law.
Yeah. So I was like, Oh. And here's the, the clinker, this is where I got saved.
So I go, I guess I got to go home. And my friend Jay goes, wait,
if you're going home, you reek of booze. You look like, hell swallow,
a big gulp of this. And he handed me a jar, a Jif.
If you put peanut butter in your mouth, you can't smell booze.
I didn't know that some guys keep peanut butter in their glove box,
just in case they get pulled over. It, it works a hundred percent.
Um, but um,
I was eating peanut butter and driving on a Mr. Ed.
Yeah. So, uh, I was like, all right, I put the peanut butter in.
I drive home and this cop cars all out in the front lawn and everything.
And I go in, they're all sitting there. And my mom's like,
this is him when he was 14. He was just showing him like the scrapbooks and.
Yeah. He was a bed wetter. Here's his Bunky boot. And it's a little, you know,
toy with the eye missing. So I go in there like son,
we got to have a long talk with you. You're in deep, blah, blah, blah.
And I'm like, I don't know what you're talking about. And they go, well,
just don't lie to us. And they keep looking at my eye and they keep going,
let me smell your breath. I went.
He smells like
any normal 18 year old kid and falling full of peanut butter
drives a convertible. Your parents. Weren't smart enough to be like,
we should probably have a lawyer here since they're both lawyers. lawyers.
Yeah, I guess so. But they didn't know what they think of an angel or something.
They're just like, Oh, this is, we'll settle this up and get this over with.
So the guy goes, a guy says,
you ran over him with your 71 Brown Cutlass convertible. And they go outside.
This is my 71 Brown Cutlass convertible. You're like, well, this checks out.
And I go, I'm going to be honest with you.
A guy jumped in my back seat and we pushed him out and that's all we knew.
Self-defense and the guy goes, all right.
And then I had to go to court with my dad, like 200.
Another case solved by new Orleans.
And that was it guys. He's white. We don't believe him. You want to go to court.
For what? I had to go to court because the guy press charges.
Against you. He jumped in your car and then press charges against you.
Yeah. He was just crying and trying to get a buck. Clearly,
these guys were end of their rope, like Evie white guys,
and nothing came out of it. Now they came out, we just denied, denied, denied.
So hopefully you'll hear. And did he say like, you just hit him?
Was that his story? He said, I just hit him and then kept going. And I said,
he jumped in my backseat and they were like, well, you didn't mention that.
You know? And I was like, yeah, what the hell was I supposed to do? I'm a kid.
This guy jumps on my back seat. What are you.
Did the police talk to? No, no, no, no. He's in the wind.
Yeah. knows how to escape. He sees a signal. Then he runs into a tree.
He's got a sixth sense. Yeah, yeah, yeah.